in the spring plants open their flowers
and convertibles open their interiors to
the Sun with its new four cedar soft top
cascada opal makes a move towards the
premium class at 4 meters 70 the Cascade
a--the is as long as the Mercedes
e-class convertible in terms of comfort
and equipment the Cascade oh what's the
move into the same league as the BMW 3
class and Audi a5 convertibles
Obachan often car test Irvine ho Dyson
wolf or says the Cascadia is a premium
convertible with a glass rear window
that fits snugly into the top that puts
it in the league with Audi BMW and
Mercedes the leather seats reflect heat
and are ventilated and the top opens or
closes in just 17 seconds in zips in the
Quinten electric seat belt feeders for
the driver and passenger's make buckling
up easy nothing beats the Cascadia in
price well equipped it sells in Germany
for just under 26 thousand euros the
engineers paid attention to detail and
made sure that everything fits tightly
for example where the windshield meets
the roof and where the top meets the
chassis in the rear
at the prints of a button the top opens
the car to the sky the motor opening the
top is encapsulated to reduce its noise
to almost nothing two versions of the
soft top are available with different
installation and acoustic qualities the
top can be opened or closed while
driving up to 50 kilometers an hour
even the Cascade his trunk is premium
class with the top up at boasts 380
litres of storage space enough room for
four suitcases
a lever in the trunk let's down the back
seats so that objects up to one meter
eighty-two in length can be transported
the Cascade ofey choose a range of three
gasoline and two diesel engines we
tested one with the brand-new 1.6 liter
si di turbo gasoline engine
the new engine comes with a manual sixth
gear transmission and start/stop
function or a sixth gear automatic
transmission the automatic can also be
manually shifted by using the active
select function the new engine produces
125 kilowatts and accelerates the
Cascadia from 0 to 100 kilometres an
hour and 9.6 seconds the top speed is
222 kilometers per hour high performance
suspension struts up front ensure lots
of grip and stability and curves even at
high speeds
the Cascade 'iz interior is elegantly
designed and offers plenty of storage
spaces getting into the backseat is
comfortable thanks to the easy entry
function that sends the front seats
gliding forward
optional economically designed seats
offer back supporting comfort for driver
and passenger
with the four-seater cascada convertible
Opel is moving back into this market
segment in the 1950s and 60s Opel was
successful with its four seater record
and Admiral convertibles at first glance
the new cascade is interior seems
straightforward but the middle consoles
array of buttons and switches can be
confusing for a while
but at least the switch for the top is
easy to find
the cascaded has plenty of safety
systems available options include
adaptive safety headlights a front
camera that recognizes traffic signs
Lane assistance distance and collision
warning systems a rear-view camera
and blind spot assistance our tester was
pleased with the newest opals
combination of class and suitability for
everyday driving
he says in the Cascade is equally fit
for leisurely and sporty driving the
steering is very direct the brakes are
powerful and the 170 horsepower engine
is quite adequate for the vehicle but
what he likes best is that the back
seats fold down to cascade ax offers a
lot of storage space for convertible
you